are you getting a lot of good time with
your kids are you getting some quality
time
i feel like everything's changed with
the kids because in the beginning we had
this
feeling like you know the one good part
of this is
we're going to spend a lot of time with
the kids
and at some point the kids are letting
us know that they've had enough
yeah of us and it's way too much
and they would like us to go away and
and it hurts like i could feel it now
like too much parents because you know
when we were kids we didn't want to hang
out with our parents
we all have this expectation they want
to hang out with us
which they don't no but we grew up in a
different time my parents
when i was growing up it was made very
clear everyone stay away from everybody
nobody let's just get through life let's
get to the grave
and not talk about anything let's not
look at each other
uh you know now then this became this
whole thing that we're expected to
really live and enjoy with each other as
we grow up that never happened before
that's a new thing yeah the whole idea
that you're supposed to be your kid's
best friend
no that's awful it's terrible
your parents are your best friends no
of course not they have a lot of common
with them and they hang out a lot
it reminds me nor macdonald i think once
said that he
he said i went home for uh christmas
and uh it was terrible i accidentally
made eye contact with my father
i thought that i can relate to i was
thinking
i know is it your your daughter
iris is i think
uh this is her senior year is she
driving yet
uh she is uh driving but
she's supposed to take her driver's test
but i don't know if you're allowed to
take a driver's test right now i
i think there's like an 11 month backup
so i'm happy about that i want to delay
her driving as much as possible she's
kind of lazy
about getting those things done and then
i'm
purposely not getting on the wait list
for the test so that she's like
22 before it happens yeah i want my kids
to be in their mid-50s
when they start driving does she have to
get her own car then
when it's time for her to drive is she
gonna have to get her own car
this is a good question because uh
there's some expectation that we'll get
her something
um my i got mod uh a
volvo you know you try to get a safe car
uh yeah i like going to look for cars
uh with the kids uh because i
the salesman do a funny thing is they
always [ __ ] talk
other kinds of cars but act like they're
not
doing it you know so if you say like
well you know we had a prius before
those are great cars i mean i i mean i
have a friend who got sterile from one
but it's a pretty car it's a it's a
pretty car
those batteries sometimes just explode
out of nowhere
and i think there's something in the
battery where you can't put the fire out
but yeah i mean it's it's a handsome car
if you want to go that way you can go
that way
yeah no they always have a way of
disparaging a car that's even famously
great and it's like just think of the
nicest car you can think of like a
mercedes they'll find a way
if you're talking to someone who doesn't
sell a mercedes and you mention
mercedes are really nice cars they'll
find a way to say that's a crappy car
i mean it's a weird model this year you
kind of look like a klingon when you
drive it
but uh it's i mean you know it's a solid
car
it's a little overpriced it's a little
overpriced but uh
yeah i mean maybe not this year